mes amis bonsoir
l'actualité va vite je me suis rendu
donc à l'elysée et l'idée m'est venue
chemin faisant qu'il était peut être
honnête de profiter de cette proximité
pour poser une dernière fois au général
de gaulle
la question que déjà je lui avais
présenté hier j'ai été reçu par monsieur
le chef du service de presse monsieur
pérol et après un court entretien
monsieur pérol a tenu à me faire une
nouvelle réponse du général à mal être
il n'était plus question de temps perdu
le général déclarait avoir pris
connaissance de mal être il avait vu et
entendu à la télévision ce que les
journaux ont appelé ma supplique au
général et me dit et on le général qui
répondent toujours répondra à votre
l'être mais il ne pourra le faire
qu'après le 5 décembre
car il estime que le président de la
république qu'il est encore ne peut
entamer des pourparlers électoraux avec
le candidat que je suis il y va
pense-t-il de la dignité de sa charge
on a le droit d'être de cet avis je suis
résolument contre
ça n'est pas le lieu de m'en expliquer
et malgré tout j'ai exposé à monsieur
pérol ce que je pensais sur ce point par
contre monsieur pérol m'a répondu de la
part du général et m'a autorisée du
reste à faire connaître que le général
n'avait reçu mon message ni comme une
injure ni comme une manoeuvre politique
et que le contact n'était pas rompu mais
seulement remis à plus tard
j'ai avisé monsieur pérol loyauté pour
loyauté du contenu de mon dernier
enregistrement et des conclusions
que j'avais fait connaître à tout le
pays conclusion du reste que les nuances
nouvelles apportées à la réponse du
général de gaulle ne modifiait en aucune
manière je lui ai donc dit que j'étais
décidé à tout faire ou tout au moins
comme ça ne dépend pas de moi a
conseillé de tout faire pour rendre
inévitable un deuxième tour
clarificateur que pour cela je n'avais
pas hésité à demander à ses électeurs
aux électeurs gaulliste de porter leur
voix sur mon nom marcel barbu afin tout
à la fois de faire savoir eux-mêmes au
général qu'ils approuvaient l'essentiel
de mes propositions et qu'ils exigeaient
que des pourparlers soit immédiatement
engagées en vue de déterminer ce qui
pouvait être retenu de ces propositions
et afin que des engagements irrévocables
soit pris devant la nation tout entière
avant le deuxième tour
enfin il s'agissait de m'assurer y la
possibilité de conserver l'accès à la
radio et à la télévision
grâce à l'obtention de ce minimum de 5%
des vous des voix exigé par moi même
dans mes propres propositions et je
crois que le poids dont mon passage dans
ces élections aura pesé me permets
honnêtement de revendiquer cette
possibilité que me reste-t-il à faire
tout d'abord un appel à mes amis comme
je le pressentais tout moment des
troubles et se drape ceux de gauche
puisqu'il ya de tout chez nous se
demande bien ce que peut signifier mon
attitude
chacun aurait voulu que je prenne parti
pour ou contre tel ou tel il y a eu
heureusement les normes troupe des
autres les normes troupe des autres qui
sont la quasi-totalité dieu me font
confiance et qui sont bien de cet avis
que peu importe d'où vient le bonheur du
peuple pourvu qu'ils viennent
helmand je demande donc à tous mes amis
quelles que soient leurs nuances
votez bien sûr si vous êtes membre d'un
parti comme votre parti vous le
demandera
vous lui sied fait en toute circonstance
par conséquent ça ne changera rien à
rien mais à tous les autres je dis bien
sûr voter fermement barbu barbu n'est
pas un traître et à tous ceux de france
qui nous ont envoyé une adhésion sincère
forte
je dis aussi voté n'ayez pas peur la
trahison n'est pas ne sera jamais mon
fait
je lance ensuite un appel aux électeurs
du général de gaulle il y as parmi eux
les fanatiques et bien mon dieu a aussi
je dis allez voter votre logo d'une en
faut bien un peu aux autres par contre à
ceux qui sont sincèrement désireux de
voir de voir venir de va renaître un
régime de respect de la personne humaine
à cela je dis voter marcel barbu et on
est avec humour ce que je vais vous dire
ça n'est pas pour vous piquer vos voix
je ne suis pas un pêcheur de voir c'est
pour mettre gentiment vos voix à la
glacière pendant quinze jours vous en
disposeraient ensuite bien entendu comme
bon vous semblera
je lance enfin un appel aux électeurs de
la gauche et je le redis voter bien sûr
comme vous avez décidé de le faire mais
réfléchissez bien faites le en toute
bonne foi à partir de ce critère le vrai
bonheur du peuple et non pas le triomphe
d'hommes mon parti je ne vous en dirai
pas davantage
je demande simplement d'aborder les
quinze jours qui viennent qui à mon avis
vont être décisifs dans cette lumière la
conclusion il nous faut donc imposé le
ballottage il faut pour cela que tous
les amis de barbus vote barbu je le
redis que beaucoup de gaulliste vote
pour barbu afin d'obtenir du général de
gaulle qu'il accepte le dialogue et
l'engagement avant le deuxième tour il
faut ouvrir un large et clair débat
entre les deux derniers candidats
nous verrons bien ce qui en sortira
les français ensuite jugeront et
choisiront mais vraiment en toute clarté
d'ici le 19 décembre 65
je demanderai seulement une petite
faveur j'espère bien de l'obtenir que me
soient garanties la participation aux
pourparlers et le droit d'en rendre
compte
jour après jour à tous les français
pensent que je peux remplacer monsieur
benedetti très avantageusement au
journal parlé le soir par exemple
monsieur qui dit barbu qui donc aurait
peur d'une telle démarche de gaulle
mitterrand
moi qui suis en rien du tout je n'ai pas
peur et souvenez-vous français que votre
liberté que votre avenir celui de vos
gosses sont entre vos mains et je ne rit
plus le risque est nul
croyez moi le dimanche 5 décembre
mes amis mes copains voté pour marcel
barbu et vous gaulliste non fanatisés
voté aussi pour marcel barbu vous savez
bien que je n'ai d'autre ambition que de
rétablir notre liberté d'homme par
l'amour par la justice et par la vérité
et cette première tâche accomplie
je pense avoir fait courageusement mon
devoir je vous avoue que depuis vingt
ans je me sens enfin libérée d'un poids
qui me pesait sur la conscience et que
pour une fois une fois depuis 20 ans et
de tout mon coeur que j'ai envie de
prier
vive la france
[Musique]